dina started her own business over two
years ago and is looking to take her
delicious desserts to the next level you
must know that they are 51st dates
inspired and she has done this with her
husband and her daughter it's a family
affair and before the break you said
your ultimate goal was to i don't know
maybe get a food truck maybe a brick and
mortar we have ludo and jeffrey here who
better to ask than the two top chefs you
know on the globe what um what what was
your your advice with the food truck be
careful you need storage i think you
know you know the space you need you
know in your kitchen so by the food
truck you need to use all the little
space in the truck to be very smart the
way you built your line and i recommend
you to really hire somebody to help you
to do that definitely and think about a
to z how to operate the line definitely
couple of things i would actually we
talked about when you uh we were on
break but i think you need a partner
and not a partner to probably tell you
how to cook but a partner to help you
with finance through the books so you
don't have to think about anything
except how many cakes i have to sell how
many a month what i can do so that that
headache that stress of money is
terrible you don't want that stress it's
there whether you like it or not so i
would get a partner and the most
important thing your cupcake is
delicious so you're going to be busy for
sure for sure you're going to be so busy
thank you and we'd like to help you get
started and that's why blue diamond
almond breeze is going to give you 15
thousand dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that would be fun yeah i mean you
really do have a strong story here the
hawaii connection the 50 first dates
this crown is very identifiable i'm not
kidding i wouldn't forget it and i would
know it anywhere so although many people
in hawaii wear it this can be literally
your crown and identifiers
[Applause]
mike
[Music]